this is holly Berlin's first
self-driving bus he's not allowed out on
the road yet sensors on the front of the
vehicle
allow it to recognize obstacles Ollie
has spent three months practicing on a
testing ground transport researcher vet
councilor believes self-driving vehicles
are the future even if Bali isn't quite
perfect yet this is real life the bus is
still learning so sometimes it conks out
or suddenly breaks all he needs to
practice it's got a ways to go the
technology is relatively new and highly
complex but in a few years time the
self-driving buses are expected to be in
regular operation and that's not all
this is what tomorrow's cities could
look like autonomous vehicles of various
descriptions bringing us to wherever we
need to go and we'll be able to choose
between several forms of transport
[Music]
the key is inter modality where various
forms of transport are linked but no
private cars they're inefficient I think
in the medium to long term personal cars
will disappear from our inner cities
our roads are already full enough Berlin
has more than 1.2 million private cars
and company vehicles and every year that
number grows by a few thousand the
result is noise congestion and poor air
quality that's inspired a number of
visionary entrepreneurs to come up with
alternatives one startup company called
clever shuttle operates a taxi sharing
service with a fleet of electric
vehicles
a smartphone app allows you to order a
car you are then picked up and taken to
your destination other passengers may be
picked up along the way it's a lot like
a classic taxi service but more
efficient are much cheaper
[Music]
dd9 Desmond the idea to bundle short
trips in the city if to customers book
similar routes it makes sense to
transport them together that reduces
traffic on the roads and each passenger
saves a lot of money
we currently undercut taxi prices by 50
percent taxi PI's moment an important in
future these shared taxis could become
part of the local public transport
network they might travel on Rails but
with no fixed stops you'd simply order
them by phone and they would coordinate
the route automatically that could see
the number of private cars in the city
dropped significantly giving way to more
car sharing experts believe the number
of car sharing vehicles is set to
multiply five times over the next two
decades so does that mean we'll have to
forfeit our own cars in a car loving
nation like Germany that's hard to
imagine one berlin initiative has
developed an app called getaway which
aims to at least make better use of the
cars that exist the idea is whenever you
don't need your car your neighbor could
use it
La Samia I just have a simple device
installed roughly the size of a CD drive
and this locked in the fuse and allows
the Gateway out to open and lock the car
payment also works by the app that you
were the app starts but the initiative
has also introduced a second idea
instead of keeping the car you could
hire a cargo bike when you need one
equipped of course with an electric
motor
[Music]